Hello Freak bitches.
Now,
when you started lifting weights when
you were 12,
uh,
in 12th grade and you want more like a
ninth or 10th?
Ninth to 10th grade.
Yeah.
Early to when you stopped taking the
pills,
did you feel like the exercise did for
you what the pills were kind of supposed
to do for you?
The weightlifting,
you know,
I had,
uh,
this,
this coach he's mentioned in that
article that you were talking about the
iron.
I talked to Mr Pepperman and he is,
he,
I was in his car pool.
He was a Vietnam vet.
And uh,
he once said to me,
I have to quote,
he said,
a,
you're a skinny little faggot.
Thank you sir.
And uh,
he said,
I'm going to teach you how to lift
weights.
And I said,
okay,
it's more attention than my dad gave me.
So I said,
I'll take it.
And so he taught me compound lifts at
the school gym.
So I bought a sears and Roebuck sand
fill the weights set,
which I couldn't drag too,
my mom's station,
a VW fastback.
And eventually I did buy three months of
that weight.
So I'm fairly throwing it across the
room cause you know you're growing so
fast,
like your muscles are recovering
overnight.
You just do the same workout every day.
You don't even feel it.
And he said you're not allowed to look
at yourself until Christmas break after
Christmas exams.
And this was like in September.
So I didn't,
I did everything he told me to and then
he dropped me off before the Christmas
break.
He said now today you can look at
yourself in the mirror.
And I ran home,
like ran home and I tore my stupid
school uniform off and I stood in the
mirror and my body had definition.
I'm like,
wow,
those are packs of those.
I mean like I looked like I was a guy
who lifted some weights and I've,
it was self validating like wow,
I'm here,
I did that.
I'm looking at myself going,
No one can lift those weights for you.
And the feeling of achievement it gave
me,
that I accomplished that was a shot in
the arm that I still feel to this day.
Mile.
I mean cause it was so like wow,
you can do this.
That's possible.
Right.
Because every other time trying to meet
girls at the school dance,
I had no guts to talk to the girls.
So they were alien creatures.
Um,
I didn't do well in school so you can
make fun of me.
I couldn't throw the ball straight so
they would throw it at my head to watch
me run.
And so I didn't have any traction
anywhere.
And then when I had the weights I'm
like,
wow,
I'm filling out my tee shirt,
man.
Noticeable improvement.
Hell yeah man.
I lost effort equals results and I
couldn't,
didn't make my grades better cause I
still,
you know,
was all of Swahili to me as a school.
And was this let twos to,
it's probably too late.
I just,
yeah,
I'm just not good at sitting still.
But when I had the summer jobs,
that's when I kicked ass.
I never had an allowance.
I never,
when my mom said,
you never said,
here's 20 bucks.
I'm like,
where'd Henry Go?
He's got three jobs over the weekend.
I'd,
I'd wake up in the morning,
go to the pet shop,
work all day.
They're run home,
shower,
change my clothes,
do the night shift at the movie theater,
take the bus out to the surf shop in the
suburbs and,
and repair skateboards and whatever on
Sundays.
So I always had pocket money because I
always,
I liked having working a cash register
on my key chain in school.
I had the keys to stores,
bosses trusted me cause I'd never steal
and I,
so I would work like,
Oh,
like 20 hours a week and go to school in
high school.
And part of that was informed by the
weightlifting.
And I like getting out of the house and
being responsible.
But in school it didn't mean much to me,
but showing up on time at the pet shop
and cleaning out 20 cat pans,
man,
that was like,
I had to be there at eight o'clock,
not eight oh one man,
because we got things to do.
I felt a real fealty.
And to this day,
like if I'm ever on a film shoot,
like who's the guy who's there early?
Man,
that's me.
I'm,
I'm there.
I memorize the whole damn script.
I'm so happy to have a job.
I'm like amazed.
Anyone cares.
And so all of that,
uh,
it keeps me on the straight and narrow.
I,
I call myself a human frozen yogurt
machines is output.
No,
I don't want the applause.
I don't,
I like to build ships.
I don't want to say let them,
and the best part about finishing this
ship is it sales off to see and you can
build another.
So I love finishing a book.
You know,
I get this thing off my desktop now I
can start a new one.
Like where can I go now?
And so that's how I,
I live to achieve and to output,
but it's not,
I don't ever look at,
I have a thing on my computer,
it's called the list.
And I keep a list of like every show,
uh,
every book I've written,
every movie I've been in,
every album I've ever made.
And when you look at it,
it's intense.
It's like you keep a list of every show
you've ever done.
Oh hell yeah.
Of course.
Wow.
I don't know anybody who does that.
Yeah.
And sometimes I write down the set
length.
I take a lot of notes.
Wow.
Yeah.
Write them all down.
But um,
I have this one thing called the list
and it's just like,
you know,
every film,
every TV show,
every voiceover,
um,
every book,
every record on,
on and on.
And sometimes I look at it just going to
have to input.
Like the new book comes out.
I have to go to the thing and input and
I look at this list and my bone start
aching.
Like,
man,
this is a lot of,
there's a lot of shit,
a lot of crap.
This came.
Yeah.
And I don't wave it around and go see
what I've done.
I just kind of go,
I'm only interested in what I'm doing,
what I'm doing next.
So why do you record it then?
Why do you write all that stuff down?
I like leaving a good trail of evidence
and I like to be able to,
uh,
when someone will say,
I saw you in 1985 in champagne,
Illinois.
I'm like,
no,
that would be 1983 or 1986.
We didn't play there in 1985.
How do you know that?
Here?
It's right there.
See.
And they're like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Yeah.
You got to fucking list from 1983.
Oh I have every show since uh,
I was in Washington DC with my,
with my first band.
So you've,
you've written down every single show
you've done in your life.
Yeah.
You should publish that.
Well it's in my journal books of the
years I was in black flag that came out
as a book.
I did a,
but I mean you should just publish that
list.
You should put it up or something.
Just
some people could look at it.
Yeah.
I have a lot of,
there's a lot of those kind of things.
Right.
He's funny shit.
Just so people could feel lazy because
just to look at that and go,
what in the fuck.
Cause sometimes you know,
something like that will change the way
a person looks at the world.
To know that someone like Henry Rollins
is out there recording every single show
and here's where are,
here's all.
Like you get this feeling like I'm
getting this feeling when I'm talking to
you.
Like I want to go do something for real.
The get out of this.
No,
no,
no.
I love this interview.
I want to fucking accomplish something.
Like this is,
this is something that I like when I
talked to people that are really
motivated and really passionate it,
it gets me fired up and I was,
I'm,
I'm listening to you talk about this
stuff and I want to go do something.
Yeah.
That,
that's all you get to do in life and you
get to do stuff and then you die.
You know,
it's over and it's over fast enough.
Anyway.
So for me,
I don't,
I don't tell people
this is a very compelling and attractive
a attitude you have though.
It's very,
very interest.
Yeah.
It keeps me going and it never gets,
I never get to that point where I've
been to enough places where I've written
enough books or have done enough radio
shows or I bought enough records is
never enough records.
There's never enough time to do
everything.
And I like living with that kind of,
um,
aspect of desperation who you're always
kind of like,
oh,
come on man,
let's go.
Uh,
and I liked that because it keeps the,
as I say,
it keeps the blood thin and it keeps
complacency at the door.
I have my bad days.
I'm like,
anyone else?
I'm just a,
you know,
burnt your bad days.
It probably ridiculous.
You're burning so hot.
I mean,
your bad days,
it probably like an average ambitious
persons,
you know,
quality time.
I Dunno.
I mean,
I don't know man.
This is pretty intense,
but,
but
it's one of the reasons why I picked the
people I work with.
Like today you met Heidi who manages not
only me,
but all my companies and she's
basically,
she's,
she and I had been working together for
Damn near 20 years.
She's amazing.
And she's air traffic control.
Cause if I'm not,
I'm never careful.
I say yes to every damn thing.
And she's like,
you can't say yes to that because you're
going to be over here on this day.
She goes like to stop answering the
phone.
I got this.
So she like,
she's the one who coordinated all this
with you.
Right.
Um,
because I,
you know,
not,
I'll just go and do it,
but I'm not good at setting it up.
And so she locks in the coordinates.
And so I work with people who are used
to kind of my velocity,
like the road manager.
Uh,
in a way I'm very easy on road manager
ward,
same.
I wake up,
I go to the front of the bus and he's
already written out the map for me to
walk to a gym.
So I wake up,
I go right to the gym and I always want
the same thing.
I want to gym,
I want this,
I want to Gig.
And then I want some Sushi and I want to
go to sleep.
And so,
but it's,
it's intense and there's hardly any days
off.
So he knows how to keep all of that
going and the phone is ringing because I
work in different media all time.
And so Heidi is always juggling
chainsaws.
And so I'm around people who can allow
me just to really run at it and go as
fast and as hard as I want to.
I call it living at the speed of life.
He just kind of go,
you let your imagination and your
resolve dictate everything.
And to be able to do that and still keep
the lights on,
I'm just a lucky bastard.
[inaudible].